welcome to your mom's house
you want to hear my topics or you want
to go surprise disgusting world
the shower how we got a lot of positive
feedback on the shower because fest last
week the Getty trip just saw maples
works but not the good ones and you
stopped talking about young girls school
dressed in Lake Forest in cold weather
whores are always cold I've noticed that
you're so much nicer to me after we do
it maybe also maybe take it to heart
how are Thai massage lady
they act like huggers after super
hookers yeah the web guy came over and
he's like so now when you log on to one
two three farts and he kept saying hurt
yeah Tom's diary on your diarrhea this
morning yeah and then sticks on deck
means annex I don't know but if the
other thing is let's talk about I had
five or six submissions of what it means
well that's that's a lot of topics and
you've got the clips right so we're all
good yeah I've got time we have tons get
too much excellent yeah okay my work
sucks what I'm going to do some work
work work work work like sex with me
stop Mini's in it well I did a great job
thank you Joyce how angry Hana we can
pay to come see me for a lot cheaper
that's not fine the mouse
oh just not finding the mouse yeah I'll
just take it back and I'll get your real
Apple Mouse okay you're such a fine
doesn't find a mouse
i doesn't see it you're slowly ability
to use technology doodad Briana yeah
that's like are you ready yeah do you
Facebook me a mate soon you know the
nice thing is she doesn't yeah yeah